Hey gang, it's Monday, for me, and maybe for you it's Tuesday, or Wednesday, or possibly Thursday, obviously Friday or Saturday or something. It could be Monday, or Mardi, Mardi, Jeudi, Pantredi, Samedi, Dimanche, those are the days that we can French, Abbi. So, bienvenue, c'est smetless. Smart, wise. Smart, wise. Smart, wise.
Sean, did you make, did you end up making a spare on that last frame? Because I've also noticed. Listener, Sean's got a pinky splint on, and it looks like a half a bowling card. Are you still wearing the boot on your foot, too? No, no, the boot on my foot. And he's also texting while we're asking these questions. Do you want to hold the records before you're done with your social media? No, I'm looking for a video of me golfing.
I want to show you guys my golf swing. What is the pinky hammock for? What's going on? Okay, so I just have a little tenonitis in my right pinky. No, you don't. How does one even identify tenonitis in a pinky? You don't have anything. You didn't have a foot thing.
You don't have a fucking tenonitis in your thing. Take it off, shut up, and keep going. What are you talking about? No, just from playing. I'm trying to play. Did you get that? How do you injure your pinky? Is that from like a remote control that was unwieldy or?
No. No, it's playing piano, just like the same piece over and over and over. What's happening is I'm reaching too far with my pinky. So it's totally fine now. It's a piano injury, is that right? I kept playing with the same piece and then I replaced my piece. And now I have a more like a permanent... You just zipped that one on, right?
Oh, it's a zipped in the back. There's no snap in the front, zipped in the back. It's pretty great. So Sean, this is playing piano, rehearsing for your upcoming Broadway show. Called. Starting. Let's get the dates out.
And the theater and all that stuff was a website or something like that. It's called Good Night Oscar. Performances start April 7th in New York at the Belasco Theater. And you can buy tickets at something.com. Can I say? Can I say? You know what? After I talked to a friend, that was Oscar LeVette,
just as I remembered him. What a great compliment. We can say that. We can talk about that if you want. Let's do it. Let's open it up. Go ahead, Sean. We're not going to open up.
Okay. It's up to you guys. I don't care. No, it's up to you. We, first of all, we love you. And I will say we did try to come in the, I know we're talking about Good Night Oscar again, but we did try to come in the spring and then we couldn't.
You tried it real hard. You know, why didn't we go? I was working on the weekends. And then during the week, you didn't want to. No, I mean, I was working during the week, but I was also working Saturdays. And you were back. What was I doing?
Everybody was working. Why didn't I go? Maybe I think you were just feeling so bullish about it going to Broadway eventually that we were just like, well, let's just keep our powder dry for New York. But also, like, I'm not one of those people. I don't think you guys are too. It's like, you got to come see my show.
No, no, no. Or you got to go see my movie. Yeah. You know, I'm just like, come or don't come. I don't expect anyone to, even if it's in the convenience of your own home on television, I don't expect you to watch. No, I've had the thing before actually where I've said, like to like, you know, my mama said like,
why don't you tell us that you're on Kimmel? I'm like, what am I going to do? I don't want to. Yeah. Send out a newsletter. Yeah. Yeah. No.
Yeah. You know, you'll see about it. You'll see about it on social media when people are, you know, ready. Got white pants on today? Well, okay. Oh, white shorts. Oh, white shorts.
Oh, no. I'm wearing white shorts. No, no, no. Don't, don't, don't spread them. Uh-oh. Ew, and white slides. What's going? Do you have a yacht party?
I've got these. I see them. Wait. Those are Air Jordan slippers? Slides. Yeah. Oh, slides. Oh.
What's the difference between a slide and a slipper? I'm wearing these. These shorts are so comfy and they're like a terry short. You know. Oh my God. You know. Stop with that. Don't ever say that again.
So it's terry. You know what I would love? I'd love for you to just put that dumb outfit on thinking, ew. Oh, ew. We just, I just saw top pubes. He just showed us the waistband, listener,
and the shorts were down a little bit lower than his ideal. So they, I'd love for you to go to just get in the car. Oh, I got to go get some milk down at the liquor store or something. Not, not expecting to be out really out about, and then get a flat tire and be stuck on the side of the road
with traffic going by in that outfit. But wait a minute. Wait a minute. That's what Scotty always says to me. He's like, I go, I'm just going to the 7-Eleven to get some ice cream. He's like,
like that. Just like you're getting a flat. And, but, but look at you, I get that from you. You're like, I like,
but I will not leave the house with my, with my Birkenstocks on that have the, the, the fuzz on the inside, the furries. I would totally do that. Those are slippers. I would totally do that.
I'd never be seen in public. You know what, you know what, actually it's funny that you say that because I have, I wear my slippers often to drive the kids to school and whatever, and they have a tread on the bottom. And the reason I felt okay doing that was because about
15 years ago, I went to jar with Scotty and Sean, and Sean showed up at dinner wearing slippers for dinner. Oh, for dinner day. We, we,
we pulling the little, a stand with your, with your, with my IV. Yeah. That's it. He, he had claimed it that time though.
He kept saying, I hope I die soon. I hope. So I guess he had given up in that moment. No, I had, I had Ugg slippers, which could,
you know, he did have slippers. Oh, so they're dressed up. Remember Richard Ehrlich? Remember that time when I first met him and he was at your old house and he came and he was wearing Uggs. And I go, Hey man.
And I never met him before I go. Hey, hey, Kate Hudson called. She really wants her boots back. Now, can't make anything look good. Let's hold on a second now.
Kate, Kate, make anything look good. Oh, I agree. Start any trend. And by the way, Ehrlich can make anything look good. Ehrlich,
let me tell you something. A guy is good looking when you can pull off a turtleneck. His hair is phenomenal. That's one of the best. You know who else, you know who else can turn, can pull up a turtleneck?
Sean Levy. Sean Levy can also pull up. Sean Levy. Yeah, that's a great point. Yeah. A great comment of yours. Not a lot of guys can wear
the white territory shorts though. No, Touched snatter for champion. I told you, I never to say that again. Touched snatter for champion. I know you like that. Here come the boxes.
A couple of words, Can we get to the guests, please? The fourth thing. Our guest, by the way, It's not your guest, it's Sean's, isn't it?
It's my guest, I won't Hold on a second. Let me sit up a little bit taller then. Oh, because my guests aren't from my guests, you don't have to
on all of this, especially when it comes to fashion and our fashion, and you know what? My guest has complimented me before, and I don't know if they remember. I'll give it to you, she remembers, but she has. But I will say this, she doesn't need to because she's got a lot going on for her. She's a recipient of many awards.
Or she has shitty tasting in men's clothing, I can tell you. Okay, I can't wait for you to chase that think bar with your own fucking words, dude. Because guess what? This is Stella McCartney. This is a real class act. This is a top of the line actor. This is somebody who has done it all.
Who's won the awards, who's done the action films, who's done the horror scary films, who's done the big drama films, that get all the fancy awards. This is the red carpet stalwart. This is somebody who is not only incredibly brilliant and smart and funny and engaging and beautiful and cool and also happens to be married
to a very good friend of ours. It's the one and only Ms. Emily Blunt. Emily! Oh, this is perfect. It's a nice Saturday morning. It's just smoothed in there. I love your shorts. Thank you. Don't say Terry again.
Thank you, there's Terry. No, you got me with Terry, I was all in with Terry. And you know what, it's because you've got- Don't interrupt her, she's talking. Go ahead, sorry. You have a great suntan and that helps, you know? Thank you very much. Thank you, I do, thank you.
You can, you get a tube of what he's got, you can rub one on yourself, you know? It's all bronzer. Excuse me? Body bronzer. First of all, excuse me? Emily, I love that you called it suntan as opposed to a bed tan,
because I think his tan is from a bed, right? It's a tube tan. First of all, I'm sorry. Is it a tube tan? What is the brand of the bronzer that you use? Of course, fucking not, it's not a, you think that I can go to a goddamn suntan salon? No, you wouldn't waste that time.
You just take out the tube of the bronzer and just squirt on a bronzer. No, no, no, no, no. What am I, Trump? No, no, no, no. Emily, Emily, good morning. Hi, Emily. Hi, guys, how are you?
This is so long overdue. You know what's even longer overdue? What? John, now we gotta talk about why hasn't John been on the show yet? Well, one of us is gonna get in a lot of trouble the day he does show up. I know, it's true.
He's gonna be hot. Hell, Tracy. He's gonna be, he's gonna come in swinging. He's gonna come in very hot. And he's gonna come in with a ton of emotions. He's gonna come in with a lot of emotion. You might not even say yes now that Emily's been on first.
And we're 150 episodes into this same, oh yeah. Hey, Tracy, just so you know, we're talking about John Krasinski. I'm sure you know that they're married. The John Krasinski. That's right. The John Krasinski. Emily Blunt.
Yeah. Hi, period. Hi. You know what, it's like, you know what? You know what's funny? I just, I think about how great you are at everything you do. And then when I get sent from our producer,
all this stuff, and I go like, my God, Emily's done so much cool shit and so much good stuff. And you kind of forget because you're so, you do it also kind of effortlessly and elegantly. And you wear it all so well. And you're not like, you're not into self promotion. You're not a braggart.
You're not kind of like looking for action. You just kind of do it. And you just kind of, and it just falls off. You wear it real loosely. Wait, are you saying you're not on snap? Are you not on snap? Is it a verb now? It's just, it's like.
Yeah, I'm snapping. I'm snapping. And I'm gramming. Guys, I don't snap. And I don't gram. I don't snap. I don't gram either. I do lurk.
I mean, I do lurk on the gram. Okay, you do. I do a little bit of a lurk, yeah. Emily Blunt, I've been such a fan for such a long time and I've always wanted to meet you. And so this is really cool. Wait, you guys don't know each other? No, we've never met.
No, we've never met. I'm so excited to meet you two. Will, let's take a quick five and let them get acquainted. Yeah, so I have, I've been like, you've been on my list as well as to be a guest on this show. Yes, I remember we were gonna do the live one.
And then we got together. Oh, is that what happened? Yeah, you were on. You had asked me to do, you had asked me before these jackasses and I didn't even know you. We're gonna do it right, right, right. You didn't even know you.
So I'm such a fan. Oh, wait till, wait till John, his brother's full. Let me tell you something about Krazz. But Krazz is... He's tough to book. You know, the guys are busy. Tough to book.
He's tough to nail down. So like, you text him and then he's like, and then he takes two weeks and then he texts you and then he's like, what? Question mark, you're like, hey man, I don't get 30 seconds and then you got two weeks?
Yeah. Yeah, you guys are gonna have to really duke this one out, I think. I know. God bless him. Anyway, did you guys, do you guys know Emily really well? Because of John, right?
Yeah. Well, I mean, that's how we've heard of her. You guys were some of the first people that I ever met in Los Angeles. You were, I think you guys were literally the first friends of his. And then you immediately moved out of city. What was that?
Would you have stayed? We just ran. Yeah. I mean, I mean, me before Jason, obviously I introduced Jason to Crat. I feel like I'm at the center of like a weird axis. Yeah. So how did you meet, you met John via whom?
Amy? Will. Yes, yes. And we met. So you have some sort of office slash parks and everything? John and I met at Mike Shure's wedding. Got it. Okay, so Mike knew Amy from SNL.
Okay, got it all. And I knew Mike and we were at the wedding and then John and I ended up dancing a lot together. And I know it sounds terrible, but we did. Wait, John danced? This is unusual for John to dance at a wedding. You must have had some kind of good hands. It was terrible dancing.
It was a lot of just like jumping around more than anything. I think I saw some photos of that recently. Anyway, we became friends. Then these guys started dating and we became friends. And immediately, Sean, here's one of the things that I don't know if you can feel it already with yourself. You immediately fall in love with Emily. She's incredible.
Well, I didn't have to meet her to fall in love with her, but now that I have. I know, I know. But Emily, I wanna know like what's the, cause I would love to get to know you and this is the perfect opportunity. What is the, what brought you over to America first? I'm obviously assuming you grew up in the UK.
Do you mean the, what, job? Yeah, did you used to visit or was it a job that brought you here? I mean, I know we went to Disney. Is it Disney World in Florida or Disney Land? Yeah, Disney World, yeah. So we did that when I was a kid and that was about it until I started, you know,
trying to come over and audition for stuff and came over for the terrifying pilot season. I remember seeing it back in the day. Did you? And then, what's that? You came over for pilot season? Yes. How old were you?
And I didn't look anything. How old were you? I was about 19. I think. Wow. Were you with mom, were you with mom and dad or are you just solo? No, I just, I was alone.
Actually, I was with my ex-boyfriend. Yeah. And we stayed at the Beverly Hills Motor Hotel. Yeah. Oh boy. That means you just get to park in a spot there and they plug you into cable and stuff like that. But then there was that really cool diner downstairs.
It was an amazing diner. Yeah. I can't remember what it was called. Do you remember any of the shows that you auditioned for that pilot season that ended up going to series that you didn't get? No, I have no memory because it was so terrifying. It's all such a blur that whole time.
So I don't know if you remember anything. So after pilot season, you would just go back home to England or? Then I would go back home to England and then I did this little independent film in England called My Summer of Love. It was my first movie. And then I did sort of, then I got an American agent
and then I came back out again and I auditioned for Devil Wears Prada, you know, quite early on. Which I just watched again like a week ago, of course you did. That was the thing that changed stuff. That did. Was that your second movie? It was my third movie.
Oh my God. Yeah, I mean, I just went ahead and crushed it. I've watched that so many times. Yeah, you've done like a mini series and stuff. You've done like a film made for television, right? And then you've done that film, My Summer of Love. And then you did My Devil Wears Prada. And this was a film that had Meryl Streep
and Anne Hathaway who was just kind of coming out as this new young star. And you, Sean, threw, you just like there was like this thing. Everybody was like, who is that girl? Yeah. Did you feel everything change the moment that film came out? Could you feel it like, oh, things are different? Yeah, it was, I did feel it was almost overnight.
Things changed. It was quite dramatic. I remember I was in LA and I was staying actually with the producer of The Devil Wears Prada. I was staying in her guest house for free if I just would babysit her kids. And I would go to the same bakery. I would go to the same bakery every day in Beverly Hills.
And then after the weekend it came out, but people sort of knew who I was. That's amazing. And the character's name was Emily. Was that changed or was that just a coincidence? That was just in the script. That was just in the script. But she was written and the audition for it was
was mad and maybe it's why I got it because I felt so chaotic in the room. I was reading for something else. I think it was like a dragon flying movie. It was like before Game of Thrones. It was like a dragon movie happening. I can't remember what the name of it was. And I was auditioning for that and I was desperate to get it.
And then they said that she, hey, you know, we got this other movie and will you read for it quickly? And they just sort of handed me the pages. And I remember I was rushing to catch my flight and I was so scared of being late for the plane that I think I read the audition in a kind of chaotic way. And maybe that worked. And then I remember being back in London
in a nightclub with my sister. And I got a call from the director. And I mean, he must have just been like, should I hire this person? Because it was just like, you know. And he was like, Emily, it's David Frankl. It was so cool. And then you got the part.
That's so cool. Yeah. Well, actually, I had to go and audition again. But he said, I would cast you the studio like you. But because I looked like a mess in the audition before I was wearing like a t-shirt and jeans. He went, can you go and put on something more fashionable, you know, so they can see you in the role?
Really, really? Yeah. You were dressed for the Dragon film. Yeah, so I read again. But isn't that funny that you're about to do, you read for that and it feels like overnight when it comes out and you say it feels like overnight. And meanwhile, you want to be like, guys,
I was here staying at the motor in when I was 19. This is not, I've been fucking paying my goddamn dues. And then people are like. But even so, it was quick, right? I mean, the success. And you have, how can you, is it, I'm sure you've attributed it to your mom or your dad, but can you give an easy explanation
for how you've been able to be so elegantly unjaded and conceded with the massive success you had so fast? Don't attribute it to your member dad either, just to just to dissuade him from ever again and putting words in your mouth. You blame it on your dog. Your dogs kept you humble. Well, I mean, it was all such a great surprise to me
when it actually did happen. I went into the industry without a burning desire to do it, which I think actors sometimes hate to hear. And your dad was a lawyer, right? Wasn't that right? Yeah, my dad defends criminals for a living still. My mom was an actress and then had way too many children. And had a hard time within the business.
So I didn't have any sort of preconceived idea that it would be a sunny time. I think I'd seen it be quite painful for my own mom. And so I did a school play, got an agent because he came to see the play and he said, you want to give it a go. So maybe me going in with quite a casual attitude was good because I didn't expect anything.
I don't know if it's also, if you're from England, it's so abhorrent if you enthuse readily about yourself. It is so embarrassing to sort of self-promote or self-aggrandize, so it's part of it is sort of cultural. And yeah, I don't know. That's interesting, yeah. Yeah, you do have, well, that's what I mean, but you wear it so loosely, like, you know,
that you're just so sort of... Like a drapey terry shirt. Like a moomoo. Well, these aren't drapey. These are quite... Don't stand up again. Don't, no, you can sit down. OK.
Who makes those? Is that James Purse? No, thank you for asking. It's Todd Snyder for champion. Um, it makes Jason so crazy when I say a name for... James Purse is way too quality and classy to make a terry shirt. Oh, no, oh, really?
I have James Purse, I have James Purse white terry shorts, fact, and I love them. Oh, gosh. Then I'll wear them, because if James Purse is making them, I'm wearing them. Yeah. OK, well, then you will be allowed. Emily, that, that right there,
Jason just betrayed a thing about him. I've long suspected it, but I haven't noticed due to very evasive measures, quote from Whitnell, because what he's done there is, unless it's been stamped OK by certain, as he likes to say, taste makers, it's not OK. He doesn't have the guts to take a fucking risk.
I will not take risks. I won't, I won't do it. No. So he literally said to the guys from Radiohead... I won't even skip a step on a staircase. But you do take risks with your work. He said to the guys from Radiohead, I want to stamp my foot to it, but I can't.
But I know that I'm supposed to like the music. You're not supposed to like anything. I'm leaving this interview. I'm quitting this interview. Oh, guys, look at his hand hanging out. You take big swings with your work, though. Come on, we've got a hat. He might not take a big swing with a terry short,
but he takes big swings with what he agrees. Yeah, there he goes. Well, he's a very talented guy. I am not a fashion forward guy, but I am not risk averse. I will tell you that. We'll be right back. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by GMC.
Hey, listeners, Will here. A few weeks ago, I had the privilege of seeing the all-electric GMC Sierra Denali EV Edition 1 firsthand. It is one of the perks of being the voice of GMC. So having experienced it in person, I've seen exactly why they call it the Denali of EVs. It's powered by Altium battery technology.
It delivers incredible agility, power, and one of the things I love more than anything, capability. As for versatility, it has the new available multi-pro mid-gate that can fold down for the extra bed space and flexibility. So I have, again, seen this multi-pro mid-gate. It is so awesome because you can literally just extend the cargo bed of your truck
and add this space from the inside of your truck. It's just incredible. I could go on and on, but I only have 60 seconds in this break. So go to GMC.com backslash Sierra EV and experience the Denali of EVs for yourself. The first ever GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1 available by reservation only in early 2024. Sierra EV Denali, available spring 2024.
Hey, smart list listener, we get support from FanDuel. Football season is underway, so now is the perfect time to download FanDuel, America's number one sportsbook. Because right now, new customers get no sweat first bet, up to $1,000. So that's free bets back if your first bet doesn't win. Just sign up with promo code smart list. FanDuel has all your favorite bets from the money line
to point spreads to player props. And you can combine your bets for a chance at a bigger payout with the same game parlay. With live betting, you'll get updated odds on games that have already started. And the app is safe, secure, and super easy to use. Get your winnings paid fast. So sign up today with promo code smart list
for your no sweat first bet. Make every moment more this season with FanDuel, official sportsbook partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. Smart list is sponsored by BetterHelp. So I talked to you guys a lot about therapy. I think it's really important.
I think it's good to get it out. Because when it's bottled up, you're like a tea kettle. And you're just like, whoop, and you're going to explode. And it's not good. It's not good to keep it inside, because then it festers and it ruins other things inside your body, like your organs and your brain and stuff. Stress is not good.
You've got to talk to somebody. So unfortunately, life doesn't come with a user manual to help you to learn how to talk to somebody. So when it's not working for you, it's normal to feel stuck. Therapists are trained to help you figure out the cause of challenging emotions and learn productive coping skills, which makes therapy the closest thing to a guided tour
of the complex engine called you. As the world's largest therapy service, BetterHelp has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus, guess what? It's affordable. Just fill out a brief questionnaire
to match with a therapist. If things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime. It couldn't be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist. Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartless.
That's better help H-E-L-P.com slash smartless. And now, back to the show. OK, I want to get to the, now you say big swings. So I want to talk about something that's a big swing and that we've talked, I've talked to you about it personally because I felt very strongly about this at the time and I feel even more strongly now, I think.
Here we go. The Edge of Tomorrow, the film you did with Tom Cruise. You worked with so many big names. Hang on, Sean. It's one of my favorite movies. It is such an underrated film. An underrated film. You are so good in it.
And I remember how hard you trained for it and all that stuff and going into it. But B, you're just so good in it. And the film itself is so fucking good and Tom Cruise is so good in that film as well. He's so brilliant in it. When does this one come out? Oh.
Oh. It did, by the way, Jason, have you seen it? I have heard that, no, I've heard that that's, it is the film, yeah. Wait, Jason, can we please watch it together? Yeah, get over here with your little pinky splint. And let's put it on. Emily, can you talk a little bit
about that experience of that film? Because it did, again, you trained so super hard. Didn't you injure yourself a couple of times? I did, I did. I still sort of have this injury that sustains from it. And I think, you know, because it was before I had kids, it was nine, 10 years ago we did it. And it was my first foray into action.
And as Tom said, rather unreassuringly, when we started, he goes, this is the deep end of action for me. And I was like, if you're saying that, like, we are in trouble, you know. What was the start, what was the... Well, we had to wear these really enormous robotic suits, which I think would have been great
if they could have CGI'd them, but we wanted to do it practically and in a tactile way. And you know, when you hear the word tactile, you're like, that sounds nice and cozy. Like, there was nothing cozy about wearing these suits. Like, mine was like 85 pounds. It was so heavy that the first time I put it on, I just started to cry, just started to cry in front of Tom.
And he didn't know what to do. And he just stared at me. It was like, I know, I know. Yeah. And I was like, Tom, I'm not sure how I'm going to get through this shoot. And I started to cry. I was like, I'm just feeling a bit panicky
about the whole shoot. And he literally goes, he stared at me for a long time, not knowing what to do. And he goes, come on, stop being such a pussy, okay? Yeah, nice. I love that. I love that for Tom. And I did laugh and then we got through it.
But the training was intense. It was like twice a day we trained for it. But I got injured doing a stunt. We called it the beach. It was a sort of big sort of beach set that we did the big battles on. And I had to do this aerial stunt on wires. And I was supposed to land on my shoulder
and I landed on my face. And my legs kind of went whoop, like that. So it's just a kind of, well, I think I, it was my ribs and my collarbone, which still a bit dodge now. Thanks, Tom. Sean heard his fingers, he was pinky on a piano. I can see.
Yeah. Wait, I do need to know. Reaching for a G. Cause I heard. Reaching for a G. A G flat. G sharp. By the way, that's weird you say it cause it happened.
I swear to God it happened on a G sharp. Did it really happen on a G sharp? Yeah, it really did happen. Poor baby. Are you really wonderful at the piano? He's a concert, he's a trained concert pianist. Are you really? Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Emily, his show that's coming to Broadway next year, hang on, his show that's coming to Broadway next year, he plays the piano live. He plays all this incredible music on stage. It's incredible. Gershwin. Oh my God. Okay.
Well, we need it. We need to be friends. Sean's been trying to get a question for six minutes. Go ahead, Sean. Better be good. Go ahead. Cause I'm champing at the bet. Better be fucking great.
Go ahead. It's terrible. Colour, horoscope sign. You cut her off like three times to get this in. Go ahead. Oh my God. Look who's talking. I know.
Okay, so wait. I'm on fire. So on the screen, whenever I'm like going, cause Scottie and I bought like six, 700 movies that are our favorite movies, right? And so when we scroll down. How depressed do you want me to be? Like.
Okay, so when we scroll down. Do you each have your own individual popcorn bowl or do you guys share it? Oh my God, we totally share. We do a popcorn bowl. But okay, so on the like menu thing, it changes the poster for the edge of tomorrow changes. And they always put live, die, repeat.
And so do people think that that's the name of the movie? Honestly, it's so frustrating. It has about five titles. Originally when I signed on, it was called all you need is kill, which I thought was pretty cool. Which is the name of the book that it's based on. It's a Japanese book.
It's really cool. But I think live, die, repeat is pretty cool. Cause that's. Live, die, repeat is pretty cool. But I don't know. But then it got changed to edge of tomorrow, which I, to be honest with you, didn't like as much. I thought it sounded a bit like it.
I didn't love it either. It sounds like a soap opera. Yes. Whereas like live, die, repeat is great. Cause ultimately the film is just, you see the mileage you can get out of a repeating day. And it's really cool. Yeah.
So did they end up calling it edge of tomorrow, colon, live, die, repeat for real? Yes. I don't even know. I mean, people say different things to me all the time. And I go, yes, it's one of those three titles. I feel like this was all Tom's fault. I feel Tom in a marketing meeting,
you know, up on a chair saying, no, no, no, guys, understand something. Hey, are you fucking crazy? He really didn't. He was, he was upset about it. If you are, you're crazy blaming Tom Cruise. He will hear about this. I'm not blaming him for anything,
but pure success in some of the greatest movies we've ever seen. I love that. I love that guy. I love his. I remember Emily, when you were doing it, I kept asking you about Tom Cruise. Cause I remember Krazz and I were obsessed with him
after all the, you know, the, the movies. Is there going to be a sequel, Emily? I hope so. I hope so. I read that. Well, it's 10 years later now. But, I mean, I would sort of want someone to do most of the stunts for me this, this time.
Do you know that the suit was so heavy that, that a man was my stunt double. I was like, that should tell you something. Good Lord. That you can't find a girl to want to do it. So Emily, when you were telling the story about reading for, what do you call it? Devil, which one is it?
That's it. You, you slipped into an American accent. They're telling the story very easily. Yeah, you do. You do it so, so well. Is it a hard accent to do? And is there a word that you use that trips you into it?
And then after you say like, you know, Brooklyn or Brit or whatever it is, like, okay, got it, got the stout. No. Is there a trick? Cause everybody's obsessed with Brits who can do an American accent. But do you think they all can do American accents?
Or are you sometimes like, oh, that's terrible. Much better than Americans can do British accents. Yeah. But do you know, Bridget Jones's diary is on the other day. Oh my God, Renee crushed it. Absolutely. Yeah, she does it very well. The tricky part with the British accent,
so I hear, I've never tried it, is there's different social classes. And so what we might think is, oh yeah, I'm doing it right now. It's like, no, that's Northern or Southern or Ridge or four. But I guess the same thing with American too, right? There can be Southern, there can be Eastern. For sure.
I mean, I think I can be very, very different, my son. They can be very different. But just do the job, yeah? Just do the job. That's not bad, actually. We have discussed this before. Do you remember when you and Justin Thoreau used to do the accent after me?
Yes. And actually yours was better than Justin's. Thank you, really? Much better. Yes. It's recorded now. All right, so is there a word, a little keyword that you used to just...
I wouldn't say a keyword, but there's certain words that are very difficult for English people to say. For example, the name Arthur. Can you say Arthur? Arthur. No, but say it in your accent. Arthur.
Arthur. Impossible. Arthur, Arthur, Arthur. That's good, that's good. No, I can never do it. I can never get it. How about this? I find that this one trips up people
from the UK and Ireland. Arnold Palmer. Arnold Palmer. No, see, Arnold Palmer. Arnold Palmer, Palmer. I can't even say it. The only rule is the R's. That's it.
I think that's why they went to Arnie. It's the R, it's the R, which, do you know why? Because we would say Palmer and that R sound is usually an AR sound for us. Right. Do you know what I mean? Now, Will, did you have to work at all
to get rid of your Canadian? Did you ever think about it? Oh, fuck. But I thought about it every day, you know? I came and they were like, okay, and we're ready for you to audition. Go ahead. Yeah, my name's Chandler,
and I'm reading, I'm here and friends, and they're like, good, we're nice to meet you. Thank you so much. Fucky, can I expect a callback or what? Wait a minute. I did a little bit. I did have to lose a little bit of the, I noticed.
Tomorrow? Doing voiceovers about in-house and stuff like that, because as I was reading stuff, I was reading four American products, and so gradually. Like a car company? Well, yeah, eventually car company, of course. But Jason, your mom is British.
Didn't you pick that up? Your mom's British. I did, yeah, anything I said for a long time, but that was about it, yeah. Anything, and you guys say anything, right? Anything. Anything, anything. I'll say anything.
My kids sound very American, though. Do they? Yeah, so they're so American. So what's funny is your husband's very American in the best way, and God love him, and we love Krazz, and I wanted to get into, so you guys go into, decide to make this film together, Quiet Place,
and John directs it to enormous success. Critical box office, you name it. What was that process like when you guys looked at each other and decided, like, yeah, we're gonna do this, and I'm gonna star in it, and you are directing it? Did you guys have, how were those conversations? We're gonna risk the marriage, the harmony, everything.
Exactly, I mean, you sort of feel. Nobody, did it start small? Yeah, I mean, John, I remember John got sent it as like a treatment to be in as an actor, and then he pitched it to me, and he just seemed to have such. Probably unenthusiastically. No, actually really enthusiastically, but just.
No, I'm kidding. But he had, yeah, it's exactly, because he's so enthusiastic. But it was like a, he had such a vivid world already when he pitched it, that I said, I think you should direct this film, and I pitched a friend of mine to play the part. No way.
That I ended up playing, and then I remember we were on a flight, and he had written the whole script, and he wrote it quite quickly, and I read it. Well, there's quite a place, there's no talking, it's two or three pages. No, that's longer, come on, the stage direction. That's so true.
Great dialogue. And so I read it on a plane, I remember kind of popping my head over the top of the seat, and I said, I know this is terrible, I'm about to completely mess my friend over, but would you ever want me to do it? And he was sort of thrilled. Did he tear up?
Yes, I mean, he did, because he always tears up, he was so ready. I know, it's the best, it's the best, right? They're just primed and ready at all times. Have you ever seen him fake cry? He can squeeze him out, like fake cry, like that. And do you remember that time we were walking? It's astonishing, next time, get him to do it,
if he ever comes on, it's astonishing. It's like a gift. Like a soap helper actor, right? He just like, flick and switch. Yeah, yeah, it's incredible. Emily, do you remember that time we were walking back from dinner? You, me, and John, we were in New York at my old apartment,
and we started talking about something. John started to cry, we both were like, oh my God, John, do you remember that at all? You probably don't. He's always, always crying. I know, we were like, John. I know, just kidding. So what was the conversation like about like, okay,
understand, well, did you guys know how you both are on sets, such that you knew that it was gonna be a good match? Well, that's a great question, because I think we are all quite different people when we're at work, you know, you're just sort of different version of yourself. And I think when you work with new people
that are not related to you or that you're not married to, you just have a diplomacy with them that you don't have with your partner. So I knew we were going to have this sort of accelerated version of working together that could either go tits up or not, you know. And like, I think we both found each other quite intense suddenly, you know, at work.
Like, he was like, God, you're so like, yeah. I was like, you're intense. And he's like, you're focused. And he was directing too, so like, yeah. But I also... So you had to behave a bit, right? Yeah, I had to sort of behave a bit, you know. I don't feel I had to eat shit,
but I did sort of uphold, I felt. You were agreeable for a few days. Yeah, we had like one terrible whispered fight on set in a back room in the house. Well, because it was a quiet place, yeah. One whispered argument, which all the crew heard. We're like one of those like, well, I'm trying to tell you what it was about.
It was basically about he had this glorious wanna that he wanted to do revealing me sitting at a chair crying about our dead child. For Tracy, that's a one-shot, no coverage. Cameras still roll all the way to the scene. It's a one-shot. No cut. And so with those shots, they're quite technical. So you are often asked to do something again and again.
And I was concerned that I wouldn't be able to... If he started with that wide wanna, that I wouldn't be able to... Because I'm not someone who can cry on demand all the time. And I have to go to a rather ugly place. So I'd say, can you start with the closer coverage of this emotional stuff? Right.
And I think he just, because of light and everything, as you know, Jason, when you're directing, you have a million other things telling you you have to do it differently. You don't wanna accommodate some goddamn actor. You wanna accommodate your wife. And they're actory notes. So I do remember just pulling him in the back room
and being like, you told me that you would start with a one-shot play. No. Well, how did it settle? We just drank a lot of whiskey when we got home. And it was great. We had these long car rides on the way to work and back. And like, because I also...
So he just had a bottle between his legs, driving you home. Exactly. Just a bottle. Why does it have to be between his legs? It's something I would... Bottles are usually too big for the cup holder. True.
But you know, I will say, I mean, I think there was a part of me starting the film that felt that I was bracing for impact a little bit, like will-off marriage and divorce, you know? But I just respect him so much. I think he's so talented. I wasn't aware of how talented at directing he was. I don't think he knew.
And I remember when we were going into it, I remember going, do you know how to shoot this film? Like, are you sure you know what you're doing? Oh, great. And he turned out to be so visual. Yeah, just incredible. And I was stunned. Yeah, yeah.
It was incredible. It was amazing. Well, you know, Emily, I always say you have to fall in respect, not fall in love. Wow, man. Oh, you're welcome. Do you say that? I like that.
You really do. You're welcome. It's on the smaller back, I think, isn't it? You've been saying that since the day you read that off the bathroom wall, hey, I was in John's first film. Yes. Interviews with hideous men for 30 seconds. He is such a talented guy, as we know.
And he is, and I joke about his enthusiasm, his enthusiasm is beyond infectious. We should have him on the show. I know, hang on, let's stop talking, but I will say. I'd love for you to just pan your camera over, Emily, and he's just sitting right next to you. I just set off camera since he's been staring at the camera. See, you think this riddled with loathing for all of you.
I had one other question about that, because when you're making a quiet place in the sequel with your husband, when you're acting, you go into that place in your brain where you're focused on your work, is that what happened when you were shooting scenes where you would completely be in the scene and in your head as the character
and forget almost that your husband was directing? You know what I mean? Did you see him as a... Did you switch off and on in your brain and see him as a director and then cut that husband? Yeah, I honestly saw him as my husband again once we were in the car driving home. It's like we got our secret language back,
whereas on set there's something a little more sort of performative about everything, you know? But I do feel he is somebody in a professional sense who sees all of me and all of what I do and likes it. So he's very freeing and he's an actor, so he knows to give you space and he knows not to come in. Sean, you go through, you were saying that you wish, Scotty, you see him sometimes as your husband
and not just as a sloppy Joe delivery service, you know what I mean? They love the role play. But I love him at both. He goes outside, he hits a doorbell. Sean makes him wait and I'm like, oh, thank you for the delivery, sir. Boys, that's sloppy, look at that, let me clean this up.
You know, there's two in here, would you like to join me? Do you think John would be as good an actor for you if you were directing him? What a brilliant question. I think I would be so scared to direct him. I would not want to. Just because he would just be pushing back like, what, really, you want me to what?
Well, I think because he would, I feel deep down, he would visually have a much better idea for how it should be done. I think he would listen to me very much from an acting perspective because I would give him a couple of notes when we were shooting. Sure, but he would second guess you
on your coverage strategy and blocking. Of course, I feel like I would be completely, completely second guessed at every turn, yeah. So you do that film with John, incredible success. You had also done, I think before, worked with our other good friend, Justin Thoreau, whom we mentioned before. Old sleeves together.
Inferior accent to mine, in virtually every accent. Yeah, it's way worse. But what he lacks in sort of accent ability, he makes up for in sleevelessness. Do you, when you did Girl on the Train, you talk about not being able to access, I felt like that was such a deeply emotional performance that you gave that was very, very small, that was very,
and of course, there was all this stuff behind it that you find out that sort of, as we peel back, we find out about this character. Was that a difficult, because you said you had to go to an ugly place, I imagine you probably had to live in quite an ugly place. And I know you don't want to maybe talk about your process. I'm not asking that.
Well, it's also just, I don't know how interesting it is because I don't know if my process is sort of specific enough to make an interesting point about. Yeah, but so forget your actual process. Was it a difficult, was it a difficult process of making that film because it was so? That was a very difficult shoot. That was a very difficult one.
And some of them, even if you're doing something dark, like I remember on Sicario, we're doing something really dark and really intense. God damn it, I love that one. I love Sicario. But the experience was sort of wonderful. I think there was something about just the depth of despair that that character in Girl on the Train goes to
and dealing with addiction and everything, and me having to, not having dealt with addiction, I had to dive quite deep into a world that seemed inaccessible to me in the beginning. So it was a long process to figure out how to play her and quite an arduous one. And the shoot was hard and I was pregnant and I couldn't tell anyone.
And so I just felt exhausted and sick all the time. So I just remember that being a hard shoot, mainly because of Justin's fashion sense, but he has got incredible arms. And we will be right back. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Diet Coke. From its inception 40 years ago, Diet Coke has been loved for its crisp, refreshing taste.
Just a delicious pick me up. And if you're caught in the holiday season mayhem, let Diet Coke remind you to love what you love. I do like the holidays. I also really like Diet Coke. And I find that Diet Coke kind of gets me through those moments because it's a nice little pick me up. If I'm at a party, I'm having people over,
I'm watching the game or whatever. I just feel like it's always one of those moments of like, hey, can I get you something? And I'm like, yeah, can I get a Diet Coke? It feels so good saying that. If I'm at a party or at a restaurant or even if I'm just at home, I guess I don't ask anybody. When I'm at home, I guess I just ask myself for one.
I'm kind of like internally going, can I get a Diet Coke? And the answer is always yes. This year, Diet Coke is celebrating people who enjoy life without worrying too much about what those around them think. Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically just live your life and love what you love.
I love that Diet Coke is in its 40th year because I think that your 40s are when your confidence peaks and you become the best version of yourself. There's a freedom that comes with abandoning the shoulds in life and just loving what you love. And just know, if you're having a Diet Coke
wherever you are, I probably am too. So join us in grabbing a Diet Coke this holiday season, doing what you love the most, whatever it is. Love what you love. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Solo Stove. I'm a backyard person. I like being in my backyard, spending time in it, especially here in California,
but also when I'm on the East Coast in the other part of the year. And there's just, I don't know, there's nothing quite like the feeling of gathering around a warm fire on a cool evening. And I can tell you that a smokeless fire pit from Solo Stove makes your outdoor moments even more memorable,
because instead of having to constantly dodge campfire fumes, you can just sit back and relax and actually enjoy the fire without constantly going white rabbits, white rabbits, white rabbits. Did you guys ever do that? We used to say white rabbits when the smoke would get in our eyes.
Anyway, you don't have to do that with a Solo Stove. And during Solo Stove's holiday event sale, you can get a great deal on a Solo Stove fire pit. I can't wait this holiday to be, and I am gonna be on the East Coast, who I like doing the fire pit when it's really cold outside. Because I think that's kind of fun,
makes it kind of cozy, kind of interesting. Especially like if you get a little bit of snow on the ground. Guys, then it's magical holidays, come on. Solo Stove fire pits are brilliantly engineered to be easy to use and they're built to last. Easy to light with a few bits of starter, your fire is blazing in minutes.
They're so confident that you'll love it. They offer a lifetime warranty and a 30-day free return policy. I mean, talk about confidence. Let the gifting begin. Shop Solo Stove's holiday event sale for huge site-wide savings, and get $10 off with promo code SMARTLESS,
plus a lifetime warranty and free 30-day returns. Get an extra $10 off holiday deals at solastove.com, promo code SMARTLESS. MUSIC SmartLess is supported by FedEx. This holiday season, be ready for what's next with Picture Proof of Delivery from FedEx. Picture Proof of Delivery provides photo confirmation
of your delivered package, so both consumers and businesses can have greater peace of mind. FedEx Express and FedEx Ground are the first nationwide carriers to provide Picture Proof of Delivery without requiring an account or login for residential deliveries. And it's available for free on the FedEx website and app. And the best part is you don't have to enroll in any program. It's the holidays.
We're all trying to get things everywhere. And we're trying to send gifts to people that are on this side of the country and that side of the country and they're overseas and they're overseas and they're over mountains and rivers and blah, blah, blah, blah. And we need to know that our packages are getting there this time of year. And FedEx, who are when it comes to all of these sort of express carriers, they are my personal fave. This is an actual endorsement.
I love FedEx. I can't live without them. And now they do the picture perfect thing. Yeah, it's amazing. I'm so stoked and knowing that my stuff is getting there and knowing that my stuff is for the people who are sending it to us because we got kids. We got all these kids and we got presents and stuff and blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's kind of like one of those things like once again, FedEx. You done good. All right. So ship with FedEx and be ready for this holiday season with picture proof of delivery. Great idea. FedEx, be ready for what's next. And now back to the show.
How about that mothering thing? I mean, you're constantly working. It's so great and your kids are fantastic. And your marriage is fantastic. It seems so difficult to keep it all healthy and harmonious. And there's probably no secret to that either, right? Well, I just don't know if I ever get it right. I don't know if the juggle is ever sufficient on either side.
I guess none of us will know until the kids are 25. But it is interesting. Like I think as a mother, you do, and if you are working as well, I think women get asked a lot more, like how do you juggle it? And I don't know if men or dads get asked that as much. It's weird. It is like that sort of tradition where like, well, it's just a film. The guy's going to be away at work all day while the mom is taking care of it.
Like it is so antiquated. Like I don't think John's ever been asked that question, you know? And I was just, and I was doing a film in Atlanta this summer. And I was sort of amazed how many people said to me, where are your kids? Right. And I just want to be like, where are you all kids? I know, I know. You know what I mean?
Like it's so strange. Isn't that the worst thing? Yeah, like you should be with them 24. Yeah, and people ask, Jason, have you gotten that before too? And I see people sometimes, also sometimes people that you know, and they'll do this thing with this sort of like fake inquisitive because they really want to know what your, what the deal is, like what they go. So their way they do it is they dress it up with, where are you?
Yeah, and it's with that sort of smile. Just so they, you mean, well, just so they could dig a little bit and find out what's going on. Yeah, they do it. People do it all the time. Well, because they want to know, by the way, so even if you're a working mom, they want to be, there's a little bit of shame in there. Like, so you're off doing this. You're making your movie.
Who's looking after your kids? I'm concerned about your kids. It's like, fuck off. I got it from here. Yes, yes, it truly, it's exactly right. Yeah, and it's that sort of faux care, you know, and you're like, no, you're kind of judging me because I think maybe our job is perceived as being quite fun and sort of frivolous.
Right, right. Exactly, right. That you're choosing having a whale of a time over being with your kids, you know. Exactly, right. Yeah, yeah. Exactly, and also for me, I find like the added layer because, you know, I have kids with my ex-wife and then I'm divorced. Yes.
And they have an added layer of like, what's the deal? Like, how involved are you? Yeah, how involved are you? What do you mean, how fucking involved? They're my fucking kids. And like, also like, oh, let me break down for you how it goes and what nights and who stays where. Are you out of your fucking mind? And why do they care?
Why do they care? You know why usually it's a projection? Yeah. Because they're deeply, if you're happy, if you're happy in your own situation, you wouldn't have the time to, you wouldn't care to ask. That's right, exactly. There you go. I have to say, John and I talked about it all the time.
You are the most beautiful dad. We talk about it so much. It's really stunning. I love watching you. Yeah, the best. Oh, thank you. He's talking about adopting me. Oh, gosh.
What is, Emily, what is the thing you like to do when you and or John aren't working? What is the thing you like to do with your kids the most? I mean, I really love baking with them. We love baking like some stuff. Really? Yeah, I just love it. Me too, I just got into it. And I love taking them out to parks.
I love a park. I love a swing. I love all of it. Yeah. Now, are you the kind of park goer that brings one of those big sheets and puts it down all over the grass and just sits down cross-legged? No. No, I feel like I'm usually ill-prepared with the sheet, you know, with the picnic blanket.
Yeah, I just, when's the last time you guys set crisscross applesauce? Like, you can't do that anymore after like 12. You just, the hips don't work. Do you want to hear the saddest story? This is a very sad story and it's to the point of crisscross applesauce. So, we had this incredible dancer in Mary Poppins who was the lead guy in this massive dance number. This guy is a lethal machine dance king.
Yeah. He was incredible. He was in the park on the weekend. He was sitting crisscross applesauce. He saw a friend jumped up, snapped both his ankles because his legs went to sleep. No way. Done. Was cut from the film.
Wait, because his legs fell asleep? His legs fell asleep. This is a very flexible man. This is a guy who can do a box split and he shouldn't have been sitting with his legs crossed. Snap, snap, instantly. Isn't that awful? I've just always seen that sort of, that tableau of people sitting on a blanket and a park
and I just, there's no way anybody there is comfortable. Right. There's nobody. No. And there's fucking bugs crawling around on your food and I don't get it. I like to, sometimes I like to go to the park on a weekend and we meet my lady and we sit on a blanket. Oh God, I don't like the way you said that.
Yeah. We smoke a little grass. We smoke a little grass and people kind of wander by and we talk to people. You should try that in your Canadian accent. It would be even sexier. Fuck, we're smoking weed out here. It is the last thing anybody in Los Angeles ever does and I get that people in New York do it a lot because there's not, no one's got a front yard, back yard, anything because
it's so small, right? It's true. Emily, go, I want to go back to when you, Nutscape, we want to talk more about the grass. I didn't want to do a little more park blanket time. Oh God. I wanted to ask you because I do think it's, I'm kind of stuck on this thing. I think it's fascinating how you explained, how you entered the business by just kind of almost, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but almost like a hobby.
You're like, yeah, I did a point. Sure. I'll pursue it. It's fine. Oh my God. I see a difference. It's back. Which is part of the reason.
So as you now have become more successful and worked a lot more and shown that you are this huge talent. I'll put your hand down. I can't look at the pinky splint anymore. I'll put it down. Show that you're this big talent in the business. Have you gained a little more hunger for pursuing it or are you still kind of in that same space? What he wants to know is how much money do you make?
No. Just say it for fun. That is enough enough. No, you want to know my ardent passion for it, which I absolutely have fallen madly in love with it. It was a slow burn. Okay, good. Because I was going to say, if it did go away, how would you feel now that I hope it
never goes away? Destroyed. Okay. Good. I was just curious because it was... It would be girl on the train. Girl on the train. Girl on the train.
Okay, good. No, I would truly be desperately sad because I love it deeply. I deeply, deeply love it. Not going to happen. It was a slow burn, falling in love with it. So you developed the love as it went on. Yeah, for sure. Oh, God.
I understand that. Of course. Now, do you see, pardon me if I have not heard or seen of your recent Broadway successes, but do you see yourself maybe doing a play like Sean here on Broadway said? I would love to. I would really love to. Sean, are you going to be singing in your... Nope, not this one.
No, God, no. Okay. Never again. That I would not want to do, but I would love to do a play. I started out doing plays, and I haven't done one for forever, and I would really love, I would love to. But you do sing and dance, right? Yeah, but I wouldn't want to do it every night, like eight shows a week, who wants to do that?
One of my brothers, who I loved dearly, was like, what are you complaining about? You just have to work three hours a night. I'm like... It's not what... You have no idea. Did you throw your dim sum at him? Some of my dim sum. No, it's like an... I mean, people can joke all they want, but it's like being an athlete.
You have to wake up, eat the right food, make sure you sleep, exercise, workout, stretch before you do it. It's like a whole thing from the second you wake up to the second you go to bed. It's just a... Yes, yes. What do you find the hardest part? Is it eat the right food? Yeah, probably, because I reward myself at the end of the night.
The sloppy joes. I ate like shit yesterday. My God, Sean, you would have been so proud of me. What did you eat? I didn't have any dinner and I just was like, fuck it, I was just by myself and I just ate ice cream. I ate a bowl of ice cream. Yeah, why would you?
Good for you. I thought you were going to say something really boring, like broth, and I was like, oh, come on. No, no, no, no. No, I had a... Last night I was... Did you take it to bed with you? Did you wake up with a bowl next to you in the morning?
Like a bad after-school special? Little Willie's got a problem? I did think of Jason. This is how fucked up how much he has fucking polluted. Yeah. As I was eating it, I was like, oh, fuck it. If Bateman saw this, he would be saying this and he would be saying that. And I'd be like, hey, daddy.
You'd be 750 fucking pounds if I wasn't in your life. And me the same. I think about you all the time too, right? When I'm about to have something real salty. You eat well. Emily, you eat well. You like to eat well? Or you're like, I wish I was eating like shit.
Like gross. No, I have like bouts of eating really well and then bouts of eating badly. It's sort of like full. Well, the baking though. I mean, that can get away from you. You got to watch out for that. That can get starchy quick. Sean just taught himself how to make a cheesecake two weeks ago.
Oh, I'd love to learn how to make a cheesecake. Oh my God. He had a spare Wednesday. Have we talked about it yet on the show? No. We sure haven't. Sean, on Sunday night, we were at our friends for dinner and he goes, and they're like, Sean made dessert and they brought out this fucking cheesecake that he had made.
Sean. With an unbelievable graham cracker, cruster, whatever you want to do. He's trying to figure out how to fill a week. Yeah. So he decided to teach himself how to make a cheesecake. It was so good. Sean, was it like a classic cheesecake or was it like a cheesecake? It takes about nine hours to make it because you know what a water bath is.
I'm sorry, a water bath. Yeah. A water bath, yeah. A water bath. Yeah, so you had to make the water bath and put the tin foil in the springform pan. Oh, God. And then you have to make the top of the sour cream layer. That's a lot of work.
It was delicious. Did you do a double bake? It was really nice. It was really nice. Yes. Well, you put it in the oven for an hour and you let it cook and then you don't, you can't open it and you let it sit in the oven for another hour. And then you take it out of the water bath and let it room temp and then put it in the
fridge. It's like a whole thing. Emily, if you really want to do impression, he was coming over for dinner. What would you bake with the kids? Oh, I disagree. What would it be? Is it a dinner or sweets? I'd probably make like a, I'm probably not as good at the baking.
I mean, I make a fantastic roast chicken. I would make you like a good roast chicken. Yeah. I'll be over for that. Am I remembering, is John a good cook? Am I remembering that right? No, no, no. No, no, no.
No, no. No, he's very good at scrambled eggs and that's about it. Oh boy. What about, and if you, if you're at home and you're in Brooklyn and you're going to, you guys are going to order in takeout. Yeah. What, and you're like, fuck it. I'm going to just, I'm going to live a little tonight.
What is the thing? What's the thing? We had Thai food last night. Yeah. A Patsy you just crushed a Patsy. I love a drunken noodle. I love a drunken noodle. Are you fucking kidding me?
So good. Oh. So good. So good. There's just so much starch. It's just so much salt. That was Jason's, that was Jason's nickname in 1998. Drunken noodle.
Drunken noodle. Yeah. Oh, drunken noodle. Because it described, it described his state of mind and also his state of play. Browse. You know what I had for breakfast yesterday, guys? Yeah. Please let us guess, please.
Fruit loops. No. A bagel. No. No. Pop rocks. Sugar smacks. No.
Pop rocks. I'm not kidding. Dippin' sticks and maple syrup. I love dippin' sticks. I love dippin' sticks. Let me fucking guess. I thought you said that we could guess. A tub of.
Chicken and waffles. A tub of cool whip. No, I had a bowl of chili with cornbread. Oh, god damn it. It's hard for us to start the day, isn't it? How often do you redo the plumbing at the house? Are you a galvanized steel yet? Have you gotten a cease and desist from the power and water?
We have PVC pipe. Do you have your plumber and his snake equipment on retainer? His snake equipment. Emily, I apologize for today. Oh, my god. It's been the last 59 minutes. They went, Shaden Scottie just said, fuck it. And they just went straight to the source.
They took the toilet out. They cut a hole in the floor. And they go straight into the main line. Throw a bunch of hay down there. Right into the main line. Fuck it. Fuck it. We'll do it live.
Tap into the city. Emily Blunt, listen to me. I have been such a fan for so long. It's such a pleasure meeting you. Me too. I just think, well, first of all, I would love to see you in New York. I know.
Easy, easy, easy. Let's do like a lunch or something. I would love it because I would love to go for lunch with you because I don't want the last image of you that I have of you and your toilet habits. Like this is terrible. I know. It's a great point.
Well, at the very latest, we're all going to get together and go see Sean's play called Good Night Oscar playing at. Some theater in the spring. It's in New York. It's in New York in the spring. It's in the spring. So we've got time for this pinky injury. Yeah, that's why I'm telling you.
There'll be something else. Believe me, reaching for the fruit loops is no guarantee of staying healthy. So true. Will knows me. He'll lacerate his hand with a spoon. We love you, Emily. Please say hi to John.
Tell him to clear some time for us, please. Emily, are you guys going to be in the city in December during the holidays? So do you know what? We're not. We're about to go to Sydney, Australia for 12 weeks. I'm doing a movie out there. No.
Did one of you say no? No. I did. No. No. I'm the voice of Australia. Did you know that? Don't.
I am. Oh, my God. That's brilliant. The spokesperson for tourism Australia, not a joke. Are you really? No. When did you get that? You don't do the accent, do you?
No, it's me and Rose Byrne, and it just came out, and it's about telling people to go back. That's great. I swear to God. Stop it. Yeah, it's funny. Anyway. All right.
Well, it's working. I'm going to miss you guys. Oh, that sucks. You're going to miss Christmas too, Emily. You know they celebrate Christmas in the summer there. No, no, no. We don't have a hot Christmas. We have a pool party.
Literally, Jason does that to me every time. I was like, really? Yeah. I was waiting for you to go, hang on. What? Stupid Sean. No, we're going to have a hot Christmas. I'm so excited.
Dang it. All right. Wait, really quick. Tell me what the movie is, and tell me, like, who's in it? Directing it? Are you excited? What's going on? Very excited.
It's Brian Gosling is in it, and David Leach is directing it. It's called The Fall Guy, based on that. Holy shit. Don't you love Leach, isn't he? I love Leach. Wait, The Fall Guy based on the TV show? Based on that TV series. Do you remember that TV series?
Yes, of course. I love it. Of course. So Ryan is playing The Fall Guy. He's playing the stunt guy. And it's this bonkers, mad, incredible action adventure. It's very funny. That sounds so fantastic.
Amazing. Amazing. Good for you. David Leach is the best. Well, keep doing, like, the greatest work in the world, and being the greatest person in the world, and we'd like to see and hear more of you in person. Emily, it's so delightful to see you. You're just something else.
I love you guys so much. Love you too. Love to John and the kids. Nice to meet you. Thank you. Lovely to meet you, Sean. Yes. Love you too.
All right. See you soon. All right, dudes. Love you. Bye. Love you too. Have a great time. Bye.
Man. Right? She's just so great. I've been such a fan for so long. Me too. I love her. I can't believe you guys haven't met. Anyway.
I know John, but it was... You would love her, Sean. It was BE before Emily. I think we've got a serious situation with John. I don't know how that has gotten away from us. And now it's too late. It's on me. It's bad.
It's on me. I feel like I have been sort of clearing out a little bit and not wanting to take that from you because you knew him before me. I know. That's going to be my excuse, which is pretty true. I got to get it. I got to get it.
You're a terrible friend, Will. Well, that's true. But I'm so glad you brought up the edge of tomorrow. It's like one of my... That's so good. Jay, I'm serious. I'm really serious. You're going to be blown away by how good it is.
And I think, was that the same director? Joe Kaczynski, I want to say? Who did Top Gun, I want to say? Or Doug Liman. Doug Liman was edge of tomorrow? I think that's right. I think it was Doug Liman. I'll look it up right now.
Yeah. It was Doug Liman. Tom Cruise did another great film with Joe Kaczynski, though, I think. Anyway. Doug Liman also did the first born movie. He's done a lot of... Very quietly did a bunch of big movies
that were real kind of game changers. That Edge of Tomorrow, Jason, you... I mean, we've spent most of this show time on Edge of Tomorrow. I know. But it is one of the more underrated movies of the last 30 years. For sure.
And Tom's actually funny in it. It's like a comic... Everything about it is so good. It's really well made. I'm on it. But I love that Emily. But that Emily, what a... She really is the real life Mary Poppins.
No, she's something else, man. Yeah, she's just a great friend. And I meant it when I... We should have gone further on that answer about how what's the secret sauce to her being so goddamn affable and personable and genuine. Yeah, well, it's what you always say.
It's the sexy indifference. Well, but yeah. But for her, it's not put on. She doesn't do it. She's very comfortable. She's confident. Her mom and dad are really nice. She comes from a normal place.
She had a... And I think that that lays the base for being a very sort of normal, comfortable person. She's not insecure. Everybody's got their regular stuff as human beings. But it's not like she's not doing it out of a place of pain or whatever. She's doing it all because she loves to do it
and she's a good person. She's very, very down to earth as you guys know. And I feel like that's just the way she wants to be and would be like that with or without fame and success. And she and John are great together. They're very good sort of yin-yang too. They work off each other very well. And I joke about John's enthusiasm in the best way
because I love him. He's like a puppy. I always describe him. He's like a big... Well, because they fell in respect. They didn't fall in love. They fell in respect. Holy fuck.
So listen, but... I just can't believe you tattooed that to the small. You're back. It's just... That's excessive. Aren't you excited about her new movie called What's It Called Again? What's It Called?
The Fall... Guy! Everybody! You can't say guy. By the way, why do you go... Yeah, but it's... Guy's not by. But why do you always go up?
Why are you yelling? And why does it always go high? And then you repeat it? And you repeat it? Like, how did that become what it is? Because... Yeah. Like you make it worse.
You know what? I've decided that for all these... I mean, first of all, stop pumping the air. And you can't say guy. What you need to do if you're worried about having a sign off, you always have to have one in your pocket on stand. Yeah!
Nailed it! Smart. Wise. Smart. Wise. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco,
and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.